there's a new way to buy and sell used
cars in las vegas it's called
carvana and you may have seen its car
vending machine located next to i-15
south
right between spring mountain and
flamingo a news now reporter kristen
drummond showing us the latest
e-commerce business setting up shop
take a drive on i-15 south to the right
appears a large glass case
full of cars it looks great and colorful
causing curiosity among
some in the valley i just drove down the
freeway and
i see you know it looks looks pretty
cool dominic chong and his son decide to
take a detour to find
carvana the first car vending machine
location for the e-commerce company in
nevada
something new to bringing it to vegas do
you know what they do
no not really it's it's it's new new
generations so
it's definitely the future carvana
allows anyone to buy
and sell used cars online but what makes
it unique
the car vending machine customers can
eventually choose to come here for
pickup
and watch their car come down the glass
tower i do think this is something
that's going to be a change
in the direction going forward rick alba
is also driving by to see the
construction progress
he says this offers another option
especially during the pandemic
given the circumstance of the social
distancing and
that being factored in today it's also
very helpful
we reached out to carvana a company
spokesperson tells us
they have nothing to share at the moment
but will when the time comes
i'm kristen drummond reporting 8 news
now all right kristin carvana has car
vending machines in more than 10 states
around the country were waiting to see
when this location
comes online ted